المشاهدين قالها رئيس الوكرانيفا انه سيتم
تمديده اتفاقيه الحبوب 120 يوما اضاف
زلانسكي في تغريده على تويتر ان اوكرانيا
والامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
بوتياريش والرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
اتخذوا قرار رئيسا في الكفاح العالمي ضد
ازمه الغذائي حسب تعبيرعبيره
اعلان رسميا من الشركاء بهذا الخصوص من
جهه قال ابو تيرش انها الامم المتحده
ستلتزم بازاله العقبه المتبقيه امام تصدير
الغذاء والاسمده من روسيا
من كياب الان ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
المعتز بالله حسن معتز بالله اذا تفاصيل
لهذا الاتفاق الذي اعلن
كمان الرئيس الاوكراني فان هذه الاتفاقيه
ستمدد الى 120 يوما وان الشركاء سيعلنون
لاحقا عن ذلك والفعل سمعنا من الامين
العام لممتحنه ذلك وسمعنا تصحيح
لهذا الكلام من الجانب التركي وان لم يكن
يعلن رسميا من الاجانب من روسيا ومن تركيا
بشكل رسمي ان هذه الاتفاقيه قد تمديدها
كان هناك خشيه من ان لا يتم تمديد هذه
الاتفاقيه همم وجود عوائق في سبيل تمديد
هذه الاتفاقيه ولكن اليوم مع حديث الرئيس
عن هذا التمديد بالتالي لدينا على الاقل
120 يوما ستعمل بها هذه الاتفاقيه مع حديث
الاوكرانيين عن انهم يرغبون في ان لو كانت
هذه الاتفاقيه تمدد لعام كامل كما اعلن
الاوكرانيون وعلى لساني وزير البنا
التحتيه الاوكرانيه رغبه اوكرانيا في
اضافه موانئ جديده همم لهذه الاتفاقيه
وتحديدا مدينه ميكو لايف هذه المده مده
120 يوما يرى الاوكرانيون انها يمكن ان
تكون اطول من ذلك بوفقه الاتفاقات التي تم
توقيعها في اسطنبول وهذه المده في سبيل
تحقيقها يمكن اا ان يقوم همم مجلس التنسيق
المشترك
بما يتوجب الاستمرارها وقد وعد
الاوكرانيون بانهم سيسعون لازاله كافه
العقبات همم في هذا في هذا الاطار
وبالتالي تحقيق هذه الاتفاقيه امر مهم
بالنسبه لاوكرانيين لانه هناك على الاقل
10 ملايين تم من الحبوب تم اخراجها لان
نذكر ايضا انه بالتزامن مع الاعلان عن هذه
همم هذا التمديد شهاده مدينه القدس ايضا
همم قريبا همم من مواليها وبالتالي هناك
همم المشكله الامنيه مشكله همم
التحركات على الارض والعمليات على الارض
كل هذه الامور همم
يقول الاوكرانيون ان الاتفاقيه ماضيه رغم
كل ذلك معتز بالله شكرا جزيلا لك من كيف